دعا وزير التراث الاسرائيلي عميحاي الياهو
من حزب عظمه يهوديه للعمل على تشجيع سكان
غزه على الهجره ضمن اجراءات يجب ان تتخذها
اسرائيل للانتقام منهم على احداث السابع
من اكتوبر وقال الياهو ان على اسرائيل
ايجاد طرق اكثر ايلاما من الموت بالنسبه
للفلسطينيين لان الموت لا يؤلمهم وفق
تعبيره وطلب وزير التراث الاسرائيلي بحسم
المعركه من خلال كسر معنويات الفلسطينيين
في غزه بما يؤلمهم كالارض وتدمير بيوتهم
وكسر حلمهم القومي ودفعهم للهجره الطوعيه
وجه الياهو انتقادات واسعه لوزير الدفاع
يوف جلنت على الخطه التي وضعها لمرحله ما
بعد الحرب والتي بموجبها يتولى الشؤون
المدنيه في القطاع جهات غير معاديه
لاسرائيل ومشيرا الى انه لا وجود لهذه
الفئه في
غزه